addressed politicians
after months of denials he conceded that
eritrean troops were integrated last
year during a government offensive
witnesses say while there eritrean
soldiers killed
and tortured civilians
ethiopia's history will never forget the
care our soldiers got from eritrea when
they were running from death
we thank the eritrean people and
government very much for what they did
but we will not accept all the offences
on our people by eritrean troops
in november rb launched airstrikes and
sent federal troops into the region of
tigray
saying he was responding to attacks by
the tigran people's liberation
front he now admits eritrean soldiers
also entered tigray
but said it was out of fear they would
be attacked he added eritrea had
promised to leave when ethiopian forces
were able to control the border
with regards to human rights violations
war is destructive
there is no question it harms a lot of
people there is destruction that
occurred in tigre
disregarding propaganda and lies there
is information that indicates women were
raped
and there was looting
witnesses told al jazeera last month
they had seen eritrean forces in tegre
they said that while here they had
committed egregious crimes
they tried to rape me and i was thrown
to the ground
then one of the soldiers fired bullets
to scare me
but they hit my hand and then fired
another bullet that went through my arm
i was bleeding for hours then
i had my arm amputated
some girls and i managed to leave the
village but on the road we were caught
by eritrean soldiers
more than 10 soldiers took turns raping
us
[Applause]
eritrean soldiers have denied ever being
into grey
this despite wide-ranging witness
accounts and a report by amnesty
international
that found hundreds of civilians were
massacred by eritrean soldiers
in the town of aksum in november
charlotte ballas
al jazeera